talk will be given by aona gova and she
will discuss the topic of data contracts
aona you may have seen already
downstairs as she is one of the three
organizers of P ladies Amsterdam also
she is engineer at faw works and today
she will share her Lessons Learned and
give some python examples of data
contracts so please give it up for aona
and
aona the floor is yours good luck thank
you
yeah I just wait
for 30 seconds for people to see it oh
it's really weird Echo I'm getting it's
really weird to hear myself but anyway
yeah so uh hello everyone uh today we
spend some time together I briefly going
to walk you through what the data
contract is um challenges that I
personally faced and literally also
realization that I started to work with
them without knowing they called such a
way um but it's all uh let's say
discussion topic later
so that's our agenda for today a little
bit just couple of words about me then I
would like to walk you through my
challenges that I faced in different
situations before data contracts then I
do really high level lightweight data
contracts uh prer for you and then I
will show you how this challenge was
literally solved uh with the
introduction of the data contract and
that's natural it's it and before I
started just wondering like there are a
lot of people that I see in this room so
I have a couple of questions for you
stay with me of course um any of you
working currently right now and
implementing any data quality
tests okay cool okay so I can leave
right great um any one of you setting up
or um working with data
observability deciding on slas slos
ases okay still fantastic
great and any of you who is currently
working on Hands-On implementation of
data mesh
concept
okay okay great so and I guess the last
question the most important one anyone
with data
contracts oh wow okay so I can leave
again right you don't need me anymore uh
fine okay so um who am I I'm amops and
data engineer at thoughtworks I also as
was already mentioned one of the
organizers of pis Amsterdam more
information about that will be shared
later and I also slightly biased towards
Azure fortunately or unfortunately
because um Microsoft MVP since 2021 for
the work that I'm doing mostly uh for
Azure ML and emops with Azure ml um but
you don't see it you will not see it
here okay so my life oh gosh typical
situation you
have your model
deployed your model expect to generate
some
predictions then something happens there
is no
predictions and you have no clue who's
responsible a team a person the
documentation is outdated who's
responsible for data generation for data
production who bring this data to this
data
topic it took me I would say
approximately one month to find out
within one big
Enterprise who really the data producer
right now is and what should
expect are there any schema changes are
there any specific weird scenarios with
values no
clue and as the story will go forward
you will see more stuff happening like
this but probably you can say wait a
second you're showing me ml model
embedded for example in a C cup which
serves as a consumer as a
producer how it's relevant to me I'm
that engineer I'm not touching AI as
well you can easily replace this
component with anything you want further
it could be I don't know uh an analytics
app something that further populates
your dashboard near real time dashboard
you just name it there are different
scenarios
right and this question this is one of
the most painful question that you can
think about who are the data
producer and you usually usually as it
was in this
case the data producer was not aware
that the machine learning team literally
hijacked the topic built model and start
uh using this as a stable and confident
flow that fits data to the machine
learning model and at the end this was a
pretty highly business value use case
and every time when predictions were not
there there were a lot of calls the
pager Duty was read and that was let's
say the story um of my life for a
specific period of
time so
fantastic what what's the difference in
this picture another scenario we don't
have kavka stream anymore any bad
transformation we have machine learning
model which expects a specific set of
values going
in how this table is created by whom uh
where the documentation for
this what should I expect really big
question mark fantastic if you already
have at least some documentation in
place at least can help you to start
your
investigation but this is how the life
goes and then
again who consumes this that's also
interesting question whether it goes for
to the dashboards I don't know um to
another
place so again this box could be changed
into any other data processing
transformation application whatever you
can think about that and I was keep
thinking we are Engineers right we try
to make things we try to automate stuff
we try to make things better why we
still in
2023 suffering from this like how it's
even possible is there the better way
for
that and the reason we asked about data
mesh because working on a specific
really enterpris datam Transformations
the question of who is Data
producer who is the data
consumer whose responsibility it is to
fix all this brok and pipeline introduce
all these quick patches um rewrite some
code whatever there should be better way
for
that so literally there is fantastic
concept that they came across I really
thankful that Andrew Jones recently
published his book which is called
driving data quality with data contracts
highly recommend to read check it uh it
was published
recently and there also another uh bunch
of people uh on the internet which
producing fantastic content about data
contracts like Chad Anderson and I I
don't remember all the names uh but
Andrew Jones inspired me in the sense of
he worded it in a very very I think
according to me concise way so it's a
lot of text on the slides some of you
going to read this text some of you
don't I usually read sorry that's how my
brain works so there are four
main boxes here first one is
interface second one is an
expectations third is
governed and probably majority of you
are going to say oh data governance
boring oo we're not going to discuss
this topic and explicit
generation so I would like to zoom in
right now with you into each of these
components
the first one is
interface we have on the left hand side
sorry like like this right left hand
side we have data producer on the right
hand side we have data consumer in the
majority of the cases data consumer will
be your I don't know uh data team data
engineering team data engineering Squad
uh whatever it's called in your own
company so there should be an
interface when you try try to explain
the concept it's usually pretty similar
to explaining what API is I'm not saying
the data contract is API but the concept
is pretty
similar so what it helps us to do it
introduce this level of obstruction
which makes the possibility to also have
specific agreement and if one team is
working on something and another team
don't need to care about all this
internals you still can progress further
and the most important word I would
probably put confidence even on top of
interface because you're opening API
documentation you know more or less what
to expect of course if behavior is
according to the documentation provided
but at least you have some specific
expectations so if you want to consume
the data from this specific interface
you know more or less to expect probably
you know schema you know the description
of specific
values probably that's what you get from
it
the second component which are
expectations and again probably I'm
slightly biased when I'm see
expectations my brain immediately link
it to Great Expectations I just spent
too much time working with it sorry
about that so here is all about
expectations so what kind of agreement
you can Implement between data producer
and data consumer and again it's
agreement it's a two-way street it's not
one dictates over another another it's
what together we can do to make sure
that the data
consumption comes and corresponds to
this specific expectation and the first
line I guess this is the most popular
one the first that you're going to get
is the schema the structure of your data
that's the bare minimum that you need to
have otherwise good luck trying to
consume
this second step which extend this is
data quality checks so we can think
about specific range of values um
anything that you're working with today
and I'm so glad seeing that you're
already doing a lot and then we go into
service level objectives which are
completeness timeliness availability
it's usually pretty pretty important if
you can communicate this so the consumer
know how fresh the data is or how often
they should pull the new data or um what
is available what is not and also
probably build a lot of confident use
cases on top of that and the last one
I'm going to put it again on the top
it's ownership and
responsibilities and I do agree that
ownership this is the most hard part
because usually this ownership is just
shifted to the data engineering team
with assumption that we do
everything and without proper tools
without proper layer of automation
without data observability tools uh your
job will be just every day uh probably
just muting down the pager Duty
notifications that's
it and the next step which is governance
and that's where the most interesting
part coming up um for I'm not saying the
data contracts equal to data mesh but
they complement each other pretty nicely
so last years I was working on
implementation of computational data
governance and that's where you try to
fetch very specific metadata and
basically on base of this metadata you
define specific access policies and more
so when we're talking about governance
we're seeing what is the bare minimum we
can Implement to make sure the data will
be consumed according to the specific
rules and procedures and it could be
about whether this data is pi data or
not what are the sensitivity levels
specifically for our
organizations uh the who can access this
data which way data could be accessed
and about access should it be here
forever should it be revoked within some
specific period of time what are the
retention policies it could be really
really crazy uh you work for different
Industries it could be starting from one
day to 15 years for audit purposes it
depends anonymization which is a big
topic if I'm user I have access to this
data I want to consume this data do I
have a possibility to see all the
columns or one column will be masked for
example or it will be completely
removed and then the
lineage and the last part is eventually
explicit because the whole point of data
contract make sure that the data is in a
consumable
state that's why explicit generation
that's what make it worth it um when we
starting like when I usually start start
to understand and draw in data flows and
start to go usually backwards so this is
this this is current scenario this is
broken why is broken and you're going
backward backward backward to try to
found this magic
Source then you will know that yes a lot
of data they not built for consumption
for many specific reasons but this is
our current scenario so okay it's all
this talk it's all Emeral you say Okay
fantastic I also can grab a book I can
read it why do I hear what do what I get
from that
so I was scaffolding uh what what could
be showed and in my scenarios when I was
starting to work with data contracts
first time three or four years ago we
started with a Y template and I just
came across this fantastic template I'm
going to briefly share it with you just
to okay it's this side no that
side
this is a publicly available
template I guess I
can zoom in slightly bit it was created
by PayPal it's the second version of it
and that's the way how the codeine
created this yaml file the GitHub link
will be available in the repo as well um
and it shows how you can structure it
but you can say wait a second why yl
file is it the most efficient way um
what if I need Pro above what if I need
need a
Json it depends on what your company of
course have right now uh in our case
yaml was the most desirable format it
was also pretty easy to be consumed by
different parts of the company and
convert to the formats they get to use
with and again remember the contract is
negotiation it's agreement so we want to
make sure that um there are specific
components which we want visualize and
discuss and why I do really like the
structure of this one I just scroll down
a little bit it's a Lo loan loan it
could be shorter it depends on what
you're doing where you start uh but the
nice part about
this so a stting which literally basic
explanation what the contract is whom to
contact in case like who the owner um
and the more information about that but
there is one specific component which
makes me really really happy and it's a
pricing so you can think
about what pricing do you
mean there are a lot of question about
data monetization right now and that's
also the possibility to incorporate in
the contract in case this data are used
uh literally by your customers there is
a way also to show your stakeholders the
value that this data brings literally in
many value and it's also could be
tracked I'm not saying this is the best
place there is only one way to do it but
it also possible and there are other
pretty important components uh which
literally
covers four main topics that we briefly
discussed so you have an
interface you have your data quality
checks uh you have a governance part in
it because you have for example role and
in the role definition you can see which
role has what type of access when this
excess could be revoked and all of this
and the last part is uh literally this
is your way to explicitly generate the
context so it could be yaml it could be
Json it could be anything your company
is happy to work with so getting back to
the
challenges okay I just need to grab it
back one
second
fantastic so remember this streaming
solution with a data contact so those
who works with Kafka what will be the
easiest I'm not saying easiest what will
be your logical way to solve this which
component of Kafka are you going to use
to
somehow help you I'm not talking about
getting ownership Kafka probably not
going to help you with this but at least
what you can do to make a consumer aware
of any changes in the CCO
producer you see you know everything
that's what I told you right
yes identification of the data producer
really helps indeed really really helps
and also schema
registry because when we were taking a
look at
literally the the this model performance
through the time we realized that
eventually
95% of all down scenarios was because
the team
Upstream were a removing table we
removing
field and that was 95% of our downtime
but because they were not aware at all
that we consuming data from this topic
it was not really it was an optional
field for for the rest of the consumers
but it was The crucial field for the
data
producer and bringing visibility to who
the data producer is it's also really
helpful to bring the visibility who is a
predictions consumer is what we realized
there was a couple of models and
nobody's a company have any idea who
consumed the predictions from this
models it's it sounds like it doesn't
sound sexy it doesn't sound like oh this
super duper feature but this is reality
we facing every day so the question if I
want to update a model or I want I don't
know I want to update my analytics
application if you don't know who
consume it good luck with that and just
a small word about kafas cema registry
um just choose your format
wisely like you are experts you know
what's the difference between Jason Aon
protu like I have pretty simple
recommendations for you if it's a
Greenfield project if it's a really uh
let's say complex data structures uh
probably and the bun with pretty limited
probably go with protuff but if your
company is already working with AO then
probably it's not the point switch from
AA to protuff because a has also has its
specific benefits for schema
Evolution and if Json is only way to go
it's fine but just be aware that Json in
this
case have a huge difficulty supporting
complex data structures but again we
talking here about the data contract
which is in yaml and then you define
which calization distalization formats
you're going to use for your
purposes and I just like bring some
couple things I know that confident
Kafka is not an open source but just the
python client just some time ago fell in
love with it and for these very specific
purposes I was using that uh hence I
bring it to the light here and just to
add additional thing to that uh yeah I
probably can say oh why python come on
but if you are a data engineering team
who focuses on very specific component
like you're not going to learn probably
other languages or you don't have time
for that so it's only a small piece of
code which allows you to create the
schema send it to the registry and then
allows you to basically uh get it ready
when um you push your data uh for like
the the the the latest Act of Creation
and and and production and then the act
of
consumption there are other solutions to
that challenge I'm not saying the cfas
cam registry it's all because it's also
design choice if your cfas cam registry
is
down there are some challenges with it
definitely but you can you can can say
the same if your model registry is down
if your metadata registry is down that's
a design choice
right and guess what's what was the
solution for badge if it was not Kafka
like you're already working with this
fantastic data quality tools which tools
you're working
with any
other any DBT folks in the
room yeah and I guess for me probably
the the DB model this are the closest
that could be like the base for the
contract you have your schema already so
you have already
something yeah here first we get back to
identify the data producers who all
these awesome people who create this
fantastic table for
us where this table came from and there
there could be any tools you're working
with um literally anything you want to
uh to use like DBT Great Expectations
airf flow um and you get what you want
at the
end
so data contracts is a big topic
indeed there are different way how you
can start a small piece of advice small
steps usually helps go on your Discovery
try to understand who is your data
producer what kind of communication you
can have how to create this basic
prototype of scammer registry if for
example you're not using Kafka uh it
could be just a gitlab rapper first it
could be just Excel file in the
beginning anything that help you
automate and embed this in your
processes going to help and I think
that's it for that part and literally if
you want
to know more you can talk to me and also
if you want to learn about Pilatus our
booth is downstairs you can also uh scan
and learn more
yeah that's it for this
part thank you so much